so when I when I was asked to introduce
dr. Thomas Insel I jumped at the
opportunity because I'd heard so many
good things about him but I hadn't met
him and even though I've had funding
from the National Institute of Mental
Health and I mhm for the past 13 years
I'm not a psychiatrist I'm a
statistician and the request for an
introduction came less than 48 hours ago
on Sunday afternoon so I tried to get
some advice by emailing David Lewis the
chair of the University of Pittsburgh's
department of psychiatry and director of
its Western Psychiatric Institute and
clinic David instantly emailed me back
if you know David I guess it's not a
surprise he told me he was on the beach
with his family but he had recently
spoken to Tom and he knew tom was
looking forward to the visit and then
David referred me to that most
authoritative source for biographical
information the world wide web so here's
my summary of Google search results and
I just hope it's halfway accurate first
according to the New York Times dr.
ensel entered college actually a
combined be AMD program at Boston
University at the age of 15 then he took
a break two years later at the age of 17
to backpack all over the world this was
the late 1960s but he made his way back
to school and after graduation did an
internship and residency in psychiatry
and went to work at ni-mh doing clinical
research in 1994 he moved began became
head of the Yerkes primate Center at
Emory University and again according to
the New York Times he purchased his
first necktie because his new job among
other things required him to play a
public role he must have played that
role well because in 2002 he became
director at ni-mh and is now the
longest-serving director since its
founding director retired almost 50
years ago from perusing his publications
and there's more than 200 of them it's
apparent that dr. ensel's early clinical
studies were centered on
obsessive-compulsive disorder OCD and he
was lead author on a 1983 double-blind
randomized crossover design study so
part of the first wave of statistically
rigorous studies in psychiatry which
found that a serotonin reuptake
inhibitor was effective in reducing
symptoms in associated with OCD so I
gather that this was one of several
studies that directed attention to
selective serotonin reuptake inhibitors
or SSRIs this seems to have led him to
benzodiazepine receptors apparently
because of the role of anxiety and OCD
and the relationship of benzodiazepine
receptors to anxiety then he wrote about
animal models of anxiety which included
separating infant animals from their
mothers and perhaps this pushed him
toward the study of parental attachment
to their offspring in any case whatever
his initial motivation might have been
dr. ensel spent a chunk of his career on
the neurobiology of attachment where his
studies of the role of oxytocin and
vasopressin in mating and parenting
behavior became very well known
including the remarkable demonstration
that injection of a vasopressin
antagonist changes male prairie voles
from being monogamous to promiscuous
surely one of the quintessential results
on the molecular basis of bad behavior
dr. ensel also wrote a book called the
neurobiology of parental behavior for as
many research contributions he's
received received numerous honors and
awards including election to the
National Academies Institute of Medicine
one more thing dr. ensel writes a blog
and it turns out its content is
interesting this this at first surprised
me because usually when I listen to or
read comments from those high up in the
nih structure i find the remarks fairly
bland not because those people aren't
full of good ideas but because the
political aspect of their position seems
to make them very cautious it's
obviously a difficult job to navigate
simultaneously the science and the
politics of their subject but dr. ensel
does a terrific job and by the way in
one of the entries there's a quotable
statement
neuroscience research is the key to our
being able to preempt the development of
serious mental illness in leading that
ni-mh dr. ensel has been a strong
advocate of the need to discover the
biological basis of mental health
including being a leading proponent of
the research domain criteria or our doc
a new framework for classifying mental
disorders based on observable behavior
and neurobiological measures for all
these reasons he seems to be an ideal
person to have as a keynote speaker for
this event and we're fortunate to have
him here please welcome dr. Thomas Insel
thank you
well thank you rob that was really a
terrific introduction I wish my family
could hear that and if they ultimately
go to CMU they will hopefully at some
point that's a great to have such a
terrific crowd here when subra invited
me to do this I was delighted I really
jumped at the chance for one reason I
wanted to talk about the brain
initiative and and I was so excited to
hear about brain hub and to learn more
about it but the other reason honestly
is that I've begun to realize which I
never knew before that for people who
come to Washington as public servants if
they're really successful they graduate
and go to Pittsburgh
so I've just fascinated to figure out
what's the draw and and I'm presuming
that you'll have a current president of
the United States in Pittsburgh before
long I I'm sure you're just paved the
way sue bro for a lot of other great
people that come so it's a delight to be
here I want to tell you rather briefly
about this national initiative and to
help put in context why I think brain
hub is really an exciting idea and this
is the right time and this is the right
place so I think we've found that sweet
spot that doesn't happen all that often
between at the world of academics and
the world of Public Policy and hopefully
even the world of financing which can
happen here as well so the big point to
make is that the world has discovered
the brain and as it says on this slide
and as these recent cover articles just
from the last eight months suggest this
is hot topic this is what the public has
become really intrigued by the brain in
all the ways that it might from
understanding our behavior to being able
to think about everything from neuro
marketing to neuro economics to trying
to figure out some of the mysteries of
why we do what we do and that has not
been lost on publishers and if you look
at books coming out as well this is the
topic of the decade without question
it's also as super has already said a
public health mandate some of that is
driven by the demographics that
Alzheimer's will become such an
expensive and such a profound public
health problem largely because the
largest part of our population that in
terms of population growth will be the
people over the age of 65 that's just
where the numbers are and Alzheimer's is
after all in other forms of dementia
these are disorders of late-life you can
see here in the study that was done
called the burden of this
studies that looks at the public health
measure of disability not just death but
disability measured as something called
the dally disability adjusted life year
convinced that probably robbed that
probably was developed by a very good
statistician who loved acronyms as well
but Daly's are one way of trying to
capture what is the the combination of
years lost to disability and and
mortality and if you look at that
together you get this single metric and
surprisingly its brain disorders that
are the leading source of disability
least in this country more than heart
disease cancer arthritis and lots of
other sources that most of us would
think about and the reason that you see
these extraordinary numbers for
disability is largely because these are
the disorders of young people i
mentioned alzheimer's and dementia as a
growing problem but in fact when you
look at mental disorders schizophrenia
autism depression bipolar disorder
eating disorders a range of illnesses
that are both disabling and often fatal
you see that they begin early in life
that's what that red line is that's the
mental disorders that have a very
different life course than cancer or
heart disease in fact when you talk to
adults with a serious mental illness
seventy-five percent of the time they'll
report on set before age 25 and that
puts these in a very different world
view and it says that the kind of
science that we need to care about the
kind of health care we need to think
about is really quite different than the
health care of late-life which is what
so much of our focus has been on
recently so i did mention alzheimer's
and when you look at late life you can
see this impact in terms of costs it's
super mentioned already that you know
the very high rate fifty percent over
age 85 actually it's one in eight over
65 with alzheimer's that projection will
go from five million in the current
demographics to something double or
triple that by 2050 you can
the cost will go up accordingly what
this graph shows is the opportunity for
science to bend that curve because if we
could simply delay the onset of
Alzheimer's by five years we can have a
profound impact on the ultimate cost
going out into 2030 2040 2050 so for us
from the National Institutes of Health
which is really what our mandate is we
look at this next century as the century
of chronic non-communicable diseases
much the way that the last century was
so much about infectious diseases and
diseases of particularly communicable
diseases of children that have been now
prevented through vaccines antibiotics
and sanitation if we're thinking about
chronic non-communicable diseases often
abbreviated by the wh 0 is NCDs its
brain disorders that will represent as
I've said the most disabling and the
most costly of these the problem is that
in contrast to the way we think about
the heart and the kidney and the lungs
and the rest of the body we really don't
know very much about the brain it's
actually stunning we have the most
primitive concepts of how the brain
works and that is perhaps as much as the
fact that the brain is now a hot topic
and it's popular for the public but that
public health mandate and that profound
ignorance is for me really the the
urgent need to begin to change the way
we approach studying this most most
mysterious part of who we are now how do
we do that what's the way in which we
can make progress and there's a big
debate going on that I actually wanted
to borrow an insight which I find
profound from astrophysics in this case
from Freeman Dyson who points out that
the way that our search for outers
bass has made progress is through better
telescopes and better tools and that the
same thing may be true for inner space
so as he says new directions and science
are launched by new tools much more
often but than by new concepts and to
skip to the end of this the effect of a
tool driven revolution is to discover
new things that have to be explained and
I think that beautifully describes what
the brain initiative needs to do it
needs to give us the tools to study the
brain so we can begin to actually figure
out what are the things that have to be
explained we don't even know that at
this point because we have such a gross
understanding of how information gets
processed in this very complicated
computer we do have some recent progress
and I wanted to take just a few minutes
to unpack that because it is so exciting
it it's part of the reason why we're
here because we have this sense that
there's now great discoveries to
leverage one set of discoveries have to
do with how we can study the anatomy and
that just the the most fundamental
structures of the brain and now one
approach to this called brain bo has
used fluorescent probes that are
genetically engineered into in this case
a mouse brain to be able to identify all
of the enormous ranges of cell types and
sell projections so you can go into a
part of the brain in which you can't
really separate out individual cells and
how they project and you can stain them
in such a way that you can see this this
rainbow does this in a beautiful way
josh sayings and Jeff Hickman have
developed us at Harvard it's been used
now for many other purposes and for the
first time it allows us to disentangle
all the elements of complex structures
going even further into a new kind of
neuroanatomy karl deisseroth last year
published this technique called clarity
it's a really wonderful story because
Carl was a good neuroscientist who
developed optogenetics in his laboratory
which has been a profound innovation for
understanding brain circuitry
but he invited in a material scientist
Chung Yun Chun who had been interested
in hydrogels and dr. Chung did something
that for a material scientist is
actually not that particularly
innovative but transformed neural
anatomy in a way that it really is
probably the most important breakthrough
the last five decades and that is is
taken in this case a mouse brain which
you see on the left and deliberated it
it's taken all the fat out of the brain
the fat is what makes the brain
impossible to look through replace that
with a hydrogel that maintains the
integrity of the brain even at the
molecular level so the brain becomes
transparent that middle panel the brain
is still there you can't see it until
you look at it with a fluorescent scope
and that's what you see in the next
panel the result of that is that it
allows you then to create essentially a
three-dimensional structure
three-dimensional brain that in which
but it allows you to sort of fly through
the brain and to see the
three-dimensional architecture of the
brain with all of the cells that are
stained and remain intact with all of
their projections this can be stained at
a molecular level so you can see the
different molecular components as well
and for the first time we have instead
of having to have sort of put the brain
back together by reordering 10,000
sections you can do this quickly cheaply
wrap it in a way that's comprehensive
and you get this image of the brain that
we haven't been able to see before so
that's really spectacular for looking at
structure what about function well one
of Carl dizer Roth's roommates from
college they both went to Harvard and
then both move to Stanford later now
down the hall from each other mark
schnitzer trained in engineering and
then decided to work on aspects of
optics and Mark developed a set of what
he calls Micro microscopes the more
official name is pulsed laser micro
endoscopes which i think is way
overblown but what these microscopes
allow you to do is that
than taking out tissue and looking at
tissue on a slide these are microscopes
that are so tiny they can be inserted
into a mouse brain and they can allow
you to look at cellular behavior
cellular activity in real time and
animals as they behave and he's done
that here and again I have a feeling
that I'm going to have the same video
problem I do so you don't you're not
going to be able to see the video but
it's okay I can walk you through it the
concept is that he uses a a dye that
lights up the cells at whenever the
cells are firing so if the sales are
active they will start to glow that's
what you see on the left you take a
mouse who's in a radial arm maze where
there are eight possibilities where the
mouse can run around and he's asking now
a functional question he's saying can we
decode the signals of the brain in this
case he's interested in place and space
we know that that is encoded in some odd
way in the hippocampus of a mouse or of
a human you have cells for navigation in
that part of the brain so he puts in the
fluorescent marker so that the cells
when they fired these rivets a calcium
indicator dye cell will discharge it'll
light up and then he puts the microscope
down and he can look at thousands of
cells simultaneously in the in the place
area of the brain while the animals
running around and he can ask what's the
code what is the language of the brain
here that we can begin to translate by
simply looking at firing patterns can we
decode it in such a way that we could
reverse-engineer it we could actually
look at that firing pattern and even
without seeing the middle panel we could
predict where the mouse is in the maze
not quite there so he's not able to get
the most precise localization you can
tell you which arm of the maze the mouse
is on from looking at the code and get
it to about one mouse length but he
needs some much better computational
help and perhaps a few more cells to go
to feed into the model to be able to
actually understand the code for place
in space but
that's extraordinary right that's for
the first time being able to read the
language of the brain directly how
virtual e at the speed of thought in a
way that we haven't been able to
understand before I mentioned
optogenetics a moment ago developed by
karl deisseroth as a way now not only to
monitor the pathways and the circuits
but to actually manipulate them in this
case using channelrhodopsin a
light-activated channel which is
genetically engineered into the part of
the brain you care about for its very
specific for just those cells that you
want to operate either up or down and
then by shining light in your able to be
able to turn on turn off circuitry with
fantastic precision that has already
given us great insights into the
relationship of neural circuit activity
to very complex behaviors everything
from sleeping to feeding to reward to
depression a whole range of really
interesting problems in fact a paper
that's out just in the last couple of
days uses this to essentially help
animals recover from a stroke in a way
that is very powerful and probably
better than anything we've had before
when you that's great for mice when you
get to humans the tools that we have are
a little less precise but in some ways
no less exciting so here we have a whole
suite of neural imaging tools that we
can begin to put together looking at
structure-function the temporal
relationship of brain areas and then
even doing new generations of molecular
imaging and it's probably going to be
from the aggregation of all of these
tools that we can begin to get a better
handle on how information gets processed
how it gets encoded stored and retrieved
in the human brain we're a ways from
that we're nowhere near what we can do
with those micro endosc ropes in in the
in the mouse brain but of course that is
begs the question of what it would take
to get there in the case of
this particular project the human
connectome project which is being run
many sites but being led by folks at
Wash U and University of Minnesota Mass
General Hospital there have been sort of
two sides to it one has been to try to
get better technologies for structure
and this particular image is a way of
looking at all of the white matter
connectivity actually the wiring diagram
of the human brain at a level that we
haven't had before what it accomplishes
and it's essentially essentially doing
this through a computational trick is it
allows us for the first time to
disentangle white matter tracks where
they cross the problem for human imaging
is we're pretty good at tracking a fiber
and there are some hundred thousand
miles of fibers in the human brain we
can get a few inches down a particular
fiber track until it crosses the problem
in the human brain is things are always
crossing it it's a sort of spaghetti
City once you get away from the cortex
and that difficulty for us is in
disentangling that spaghetti well the
connectome project and the group led by
van madine and bruce rosen at Mass
General has provided a computational fix
for that that does allow us as you can
see here to actually follow fibers
through these very complicated areas of
crossover it was with all of these kinds
of innovations that the White House
decided that the brain would be the next
great American project the president had
talked about in his last campaign that
if he were reelected he wanted to have a
signature science project for his second
term and there was a lot of debate
within the Office of Science and
Technology Policy about what that should
be climate versus energy versus shooting
asteroids out of the sky range of things
came up i think it was partly looking at
the recent progress on the brain front
in neuroscience looking at the public
health urgency that i already mentioned
that subra talked to you about that
suggested that this was the way to go
and what I'm
ticularly excited about is what the part
that shows up in the green there if you
can read it in the back it says he wants
this to brain initiative will give
scientists the tools they need to get a
dynamic picture of the brain in action
so channeling Freeman Dyson and the
legacy of what's happened in the search
for outer space and astrophysics this
was about tools and creating a next
generation of tools he called for a
public and private effort he said we
need to get all hands on deck he's asked
NSF and NIH and DARPA the FDA has now
joined it's likely the Department of
Energy will soon join I arpa I think is
going to be part of this so almost any
of the federal agencies that have a
stake in either a brain or behavior or
computation to hit your three hub areas
it has become part of this also a number
of private partners and you can see some
of them here the Simons Foundation has
just announced a global brain initiative
kavli foundation and Allen Institute
were the sort of founders of much of
this through their brain activity map
project which really catalyzed a lot
that's happened since and the Howard
Hughes through the janelia farm
initiative as a very large supporter of
brain science I don't think I mentioned
it here but I should have that the this
is the u.s. brain initiative writ large
I'm representing the NIH part along with
my colleague story Landis from the
neurology Institute but were one part of
a large global effort there's similar
work going on in the EU with an even
larger project and what we're doing in
the US China has announced their brain
initiative there's a brain initiative in
Israel which is much more computational
there's a new initiative in Japan
there's one in Australia that will be
announced over the next few weeks and if
i were really being complete i would
have included India Chris I hadn't even
realized until today that India's got a
brain initiative as well so this has
become
much more than a u.s. effort it's very
much a global effort in a lot of
excitement about how to bring all of
those together the NIH piece was
captured by this report that was
released in June it was put together by
a work group of really leading
neuroscientists who brought in lots of
engineers and computational scientists
and range of other people including a
number of public stakeholders to help
think about what should the NIH brain
initiative do over the next 10 to 12
years what should it accomplished how do
you set priorities how big does it need
to be really provide us a blueprint and
I'll just take you very briefly through
their conclusion this group was led by
Cori Bargmann of Rockefeller University
and Bill Newsome of Stanford with many
many other really brilliant people they
said go after the circuits that we have
some understanding of the most simple
and atomic issues we have some
understanding of behavioral issues and
cognitive issues but we can't bridge
them unless we really understand how to
map circuits and measure these
electrical and chemical patterns within
them and figure out how do you cross
those boundaries I yesterday learned the
term coarse graining which I assume many
of you know but it's a way of thinking
about how to cross levels of analysis so
we can begin to try to explain much more
about the way we think and behave in
terms of circuit levels of analysis they
gave us seven areas to pursue first to
get the parts list through a cell census
and cell types to get at these multiple
scales as I just mentioned to understand
not just structure but function looking
at the brain in action to go beyond
correlational studies which is so much
of what we do today with brain imaging
but to actually think about causality
and how to establish causality of in
going from circuits to behavior to use
models at every level to get to some of
the fundamental principles of how the
brain works
it's been really interesting to me and I
didn't even realize it until recently
that we always think about the brain and
metaphors we talk about it as a computer
or maybe as a muscle it's good for
plasticity or as an information
processing machine but virtually all
these metaphors probably sell us short
because it's likely that there are
principles that are latent in brain
activity that are not really exemplified
in any of the of the machines that we
know about and part of what this effort
would be about and getting these
fundamental principles is to get beyond
the metaphors to understand how the
brain itself actually works human
neuroscience has emerged as an important
area for us and we've talked a lot about
what that might look like could we as
you saw in Subarus presentation could we
develop a whole new generation of
imaging tools that allow us to do for
the human brain what we can do today for
the fly brain or for the mouse brain and
then finally how do we get from all of
these initiatives to something of
practical value if we really want to
begin to understand brain and behavior
both normal and abnormal how do we get
there by putting all this together the
idea was this was a about a ten year
maybe twelve year plan the first five
years they said follow the Freeman Dyson
dictum you go after the tools and then
in the second five years begin to apply
those through much more
hypothesis-driven science to fill in the
gaps the budget they can only estimate
and guesstimate about and of course
living in Washington we do think a lot
about budgets which is probably why many
of us have gotten prematurely gray but
you can see here that their idea was
that you spend the money up front on the
neuro technologies then you bring in
more of the kind of classical
neuroscience research and build
infrastructure throughout all together
they were projecting something like
we're starting at 40 million dollars a
year so we're actually not as big yet as
even the Indian project that Chris has
helped to put together but we'd be
growing to something like
five hundred million dollars a year with
a total of investment of about four and
a half billion dollars by 2025 that's a
really in many ways mirrors what's
happened with the human genome project
that started out at about 40 million
dollars and then grew accordingly in
just about this pace in this way this is
not the budget that Congress has agreed
to but it is what the these very astute
advisors have recommended is required
for the task and it's a tough task as
the president said it's the next great
American project and if we want to be
able to succeed it's going to require a
very significant investment so to finish
up these are indeed the leading sources
of disease burden and cost that's true
already and it will get even more true
with time we have something to point to
this has been an extraordinary five
years of technological breakthroughs for
students there is not a better time to
be going into this field my one of my
greatest regrets is that I wasn't born
50 years or four years later the things
that took me a decade to do literally a
decade can now be done in a matter of a
few weeks that is just extraordinary it
really is an amazing time in terms of
the technology we have the hope is that
we can build on this to create these
tools that will really accelerate
discovery and build this foundation and
last thing I want to say and honestly
part of the reason that I am here
probably more than any other besides the
fact that will do whatever subra asks me
to do but the the really key reason is
yesterday we had our first council
meeting for our brain it's called a
brain multi council working group it's
ten different Institute's at NIH who are
investing in this project
to try to make it go in the beginning
and we've each Institute at NIH has an
advisory council and one member from
each of those councils comes together
for this multi council working group and
we sat down with them and looked at the
first set of grants that have come in
which we're about to announce the awards
of the next couple of weeks but we you
know for the first 40 million dollars
that we invested in 2014 we had six
RFA's we got some 306 applications will
be making about 50 some awards and they
look through that list of awards and
they said where are the engineers and
where the computational scientists and
where the material scientists and we're
not seeing enough nanotechnology you're
getting a lot of applications from
outstanding neuro scientists but if you
guys want this to succeed you're going
to have to get applications from people
you've never heard of the future of the
brain initiative is bringing physical
sciences and engineering and mathematics
the best computational science we can
find together with neuroscience that
story I told you about clarity bringing
a material scientists together with
neuro scientists and in six months they
had transformed neuroanatomy more than
anybody in the last five decades that's
the story we want to tell over and over
again the public health mandate is so
urgent the interest is so urgent the
funding should be forthcoming this is
really the right time to do this and I
really believe this is probably the
right place to make that happen thanks
very much for your attention
you